[Music]
the amazing thing about will he brings
all his dimensions to it and you get to
see Jeannie with incredibly different
flavors you kind of just watch him and
you're just like this is how Aladdin
would feel if he was watching the genie
ten thousand years I have never once
ever called a master friend I think a
lot of my job was encouraging will to be
will so I'm not who mom seems I'm just
fun on set what's your name whatever
what will your pleasure be guy who gave
me the freedom to create with my hip-hop
background to sort of you know try to
bring a little Big Willie flavor to it
come whisper to me whatever it is you
want I had a friend like me do they
build mated his own completely the same
vile and swagger to the genie you know
we grew up on little Smith rapper Big
Willie style a little big really the
style that comes in there a little fresh
premium attitude it's really it really
is is a haka sing rap dance it kickin me
a champ he's so hard to work with this
is ridiculous reaching man we got work
to do man
we got worse
friend like me it's a very complicated
sequence but we're cutting it live so
it's really exciting I in digital is
fantastic
working with wills been incredible this
even though he's CGI is here every day
acting with me so that we can deliver a
cohesive performance you know I just
leaned over tone now whispering in NZ I
said hey man look
you must his next one up we have another
dude in here to live just like you in 10
minutes and then he got it right it's
like just best because I aspire that's
what I do I just keep the energy -
inspiration encouragement amazing I mean
seriously the best cast mate I could ask
for friends like me yeah thank you a
prince
oh no right you'd be snuggled up with
that dude for the rest of your life okay
I had a guy one time called ye the snake
wish to be irresistible to all women
yeah that was good for about 90 seconds
while lead the wicked wish sticky feet
Sharif wish that anything I touch when
it time to call
[Music]
[Music]
moral of the story be clear be specific
with your words the deal is in the
detail
[Music]